hey everybody Dave here joined by two
more Hussein hello we be talking about
the end is nigh Dave this looks like
binding of issac what's going on here
well these you might recognize a little
bit our style is the newest game from Ed
McMillan it's a little bit meat boy but
it's very much its own Beast
I've played 56 minutes and 52 seconds of
it died 386 times blood yard hmm so I
really like drawing like really simple
sir cause we have sad faces on them
doesn't he yes whole aesthetic this game
has quite a sad aesthetic ways this is a
doing a let's play he's doing it for us
we don't need to do anything I'm into
this sweeter sweeter see here I don't
know I have to actually play now big fan
of this music not a fan of that noise I
hope that is an action of the game it's
inappropriate less playstyle response
he's got zero viewers and the reason
he's busy reviewers is because later
everyone's dead oh wow were they sent to
hell by their mothers basically ash is
now he's not happy because his games
broken I'm gonna skip the rest the intro
because it is a little bit long run
against the gameplay does you beg for
subscribers
Peter the the TV off people to go to the
his patreon so the story is is there's
bidded apocalypse and he's ash this
guy's at the only survivor and what he's
gonna try and do now his video games
broke is he wants to build a friend so
he needs to find a body a head a heart
soul and various game pieces and I mean
he also collects tumors along the way
that song each level has a tumor the
owner collecting it's great dark bright
you know so you see it is a little like
super meatboy road but Super Meat Boy
felt a little faster whereas this feels
like you got to put a little bit more
thought into it
oh it's you must be nice being alive and
all that when I died that tumor wiggled
out it's been floating up there from for
years watching me please don't take it
what particular mmm how long has this
game been in development I no idea he
kind of surprised everyone we released
it was just like it's out go get it
what is this music all the music that is
used so far is like remixes of publicly
available tracks right I'm not sure
likes long before some of the music you
might might recognize what this is a
secret level hello
aha I need some I can relate to cluster
centers gotta stick together you know
yeah this is a important part of a group
that way you can see know who's good and
who's evil
obviously we're the good ones in every
house or here's seriously think about it
there's a lot of exploration in this
game like I only know that you can swim
and ground-pound because I've played
this game for an hour now five she was
mature yeah the air the promise is a
little dark I've I guess I've only
played the first hour and I haven't got
extremely far that's time I think I've
got to like the fourth stage yeah and
and the it's not exactly clear what's
happening in the story but you know it's
got the same like you see it's got the
same kind of style as Super Meat Boy
whereas Super Meat Boy was a lot of wall
running and like bouncing like for
example Steve me boy you could bounce
back off a wall yeah I miss you you you
hold on to these hooks and these corners
yeah so it's not quite as quite is it
like I said not quite as intense yeah
boy in some ways gives you a little more
time to think that some of the puzzles
are actually harder yeah why have you
chosen to attack that enemy now sorry I
clicked that you a tumor is it part of
completion yeah
so yeah I'm not sure each other have a
streamer and tumors are required to
unlock sonar press all right so like you
have to be X number of X amount of
mutated to get into a certain area yeah
when I use the hang off a wall I pull
out from from it and then I do a jump
and go like super far but when I didn't
pulled out but when I didn't pull out
words I'd mostly just go up higher I
call it the pull out method well I made
that one up years ago I imagined it
would get a lot more of a laughs please
leave enough
I love these skeletons are hilarious
scallions are consistently funny in
video games lately between too spoopy
yeah I'm not sure why the apocalypse has
happened in this game um I bet it's not
exactly being explainers from why I've
seen the game yet this is an area I've
not been to yet Metroid action here it's
not M oh I didn't even get that one it's
gone
so like it's it's similar it has like
the Metroid style of like going
backwards and stuff but it doesn't at
least from what I've played so far what
about please from what I've seen so far
they don't do the metroidvania thing of
like locking in area by abilities they
lock it off by you just learning things
okay so it's it it spends a long time
before it teaches you that you can like
run like God the hidden spice takes a
long time before they can tell you later
or you can ground pound stuff yeah and
then by that time you like the fourth
level in just giving that big tumor that
is cheeky this music like you say before
isn't this like the Alton Towers music
yeah a lot of the music so far has been
like Oh
license license free music remixed music
is great though bit more love into it
that's why I asked well how long has it
been in development for it because seems
like he's tried to save himself some
time using something yeah I don't know
it's kind of a I think it was like a pro
I want to say this game was teased yeah
and then yeah I'd kind of just tweeted
out being like it's out don't get it
he's making a bunch of games at the same
time now there's no bomb bows and then
dormant as well yeah I loves you so far
it's it's scratched that meatboy edge
that I didn't actually know I had that's
like you know I actually do kind of miss
play Meat Boy how do I get that edge
around your crotch area because I'm like
something different
know that mean boy is fine okay call
that meat boy is aweso all right
I wish I hadn't called it meat boy
though yeah I really read that get over
on that thing
I'm dying way less than I thought I
would yeah I suppose I deserve it before
it is a test of patience as much say is
like Dexter E yeah it's gonna I think
there's methods that you can go through
these levels fast and this will be a
game that like you know the speed when
he's gonna get hold of again as well
okay over there
but dad's got a tumor so I'm just gonna
leave that I guess I spent too long
underneath down there or you can go down
area yes boy you wrong damn gather you
know in spend more oh no I've say won't
spend an exceptional amount of time I
don't know well just because a little
bit as you see if you die when you get
the tumor yeah level and I know it's
jump distance yeah yes that one way let
the longer you hold the button there you
go nicely platformer stuff I I played a
little bit of this at e3 just a teaser
and are the tumors there that comes down
after how am I supposed to get that
though wait is it on a timer or is it on
you reaching some polymer oh you the if
you jump onto white you know if you jump
onto the pillar there it'll start moving
the pit in the middle yeah this thing as
in I think you need to go across start
knows I'm coming some platform yeah grab
it and learn to do that so just go all
the way across oh you mean just go into
the next yeah and wait come backwards
and now come back quickly
but then okay when it comes back collect
it and then jump back onto the pillar on
the other side oh yeah
Oh scary there we go
the tremors are way easy to get then
like the the bandages were in Sydney boy
but I think that's actually just because
the tumours are required for things
where is um where's the chin too much
it's not a doula it's not I've not found
any of the friend pieces yet that's a
fine like just a body and a head and a
heart and stuff oh yeah nothing ugh
myself out now I can't get back in no
you can go down but I don't that's gonna
get me anyway
you can replay all these levels like you
unlock a warp system after you get
through the first area yeah well how you
supposed to get that that nice first
rats me let's go oh let's go there we go
right and like this is the first first
area and it's white brute sauce it it
gets way more room does it all have this
black and white cific no it changes
color and they'll be like pollution
clouds and water that you've been
getting through the system hmm are these
key system it is PC only at the moment
if it follows the pattern of other games
they'll probably come to console
literally everything
I mean how that minigames obviously
we've seen binding of issac on a switch
and it's pretty sure I can run binding
of issac on my microwave I mean yeah the
newest one maybe now it's been optimized
but like not the original one is in
horrible flash that game was I'd love to
play this on switch
oh yeah like it perfect game straight
edge that was a response to Dave almost
oh no no the Chairman the thing is this
game can get so frustrating in the
levels having it in a hand held console
where you want to just throw so angry
and whip it across the room might
actually be kind of dangerous the two
more yeah
Dave becomes an old man whinnies oh oh
oh
where's it going and I feel like I made
it just for the noise I make it like
well I played Super Meat Boy it was
constantly like that just it's always
this did let's go boys let's go oh no it
was me ad Oh me at son of you making
noise it's like some of the trickier
levels like the commentary credit goes
out their necks just like oh okay
I don't know at the end of ugh I think
it's just like speed yeah let's go let's
go let's go
ah [ __ ] see thing is now but in my
head I want a streamer yeah I have to
get it approved to the Internet you can
do no I can get it I can get it I can
get it oh so close
actually I don't know you got a jump to
it collect it on the way up
okay now I've got that good plan
just watch this Drive no mmm watch this
Drive
oh I see you jump from that second
pillar let go down a bit and then try
and jump over mm-hmm
you might be a bit long yeah like that
oh yeah there it goes
Oh quick fast so mad
could I be can I do it from like here
then just like now yeah laughs down the
ship you really do have to wait for the
top one for some reason I think it's it
gains momentum mmm like a little like a
little bit like a little bit like a
little bit later
yes no my head I keep forgetting that
yes let's go let's go let's go let's go
let's go
you know know what screw this you gonna
stay that or get it all at a time
yes I'll cool that I was claps now just
just what I want
good oh wait how do I get that one
that's got to be a coming back from you
why okay so the arid flats this is the
next like area - okay then the remains
of our ancestors down there their guts
connect all underground at night I can
hear them whispering help us we got
burning in hell what something like that
it's hard to hear them over moaning
screams anyway I just stopped talking
someone this tumor
I like the the font well as to this
Canon Blair
by only a this this thing here is just
the warp system you know back to some an
area that you've been before
obviously I've missed some tumors and
had a tumor
[Music]
in this place the music in this level is
I think my favorite in the game so far
mm-hmm
it's not familiar to me so it might be
an original composition but you can tell
them like that the monotone color scheme
is still there but yeah a little more
familiar black and white and the
background colors do change depending on
the environment and the kind of hazards
that end up in the level yeah you need
to have not have too much visual clutter
for a game like this oh yeah sure Super
Meat Boy did that extremely well yeah a
really well what's that guy over there
it's gone right yeah go over to and say
hello hello
would you like to see your fate yeah
it's right ov eyes 50 lifetimes of
suffering to enter please return when
your tumor has grown we'll be waiting so
I need 50 tumors together 29 been sold
by all this tumor talk come back when
your tumors pear yeah it says it kind of
has some very dark subtleties to it and
the guys only got one eye as well yes
Skellington there are others close by
crazies who believe in what they call
the ascension they hide just out of you
some are both similar below don't try
and find them and definitely never
speaks stick to the linear path kid
exploration can only lead to
disappointment I explored myself once
and now I'm dead think about it drop
down
we're back to the old school music near
the old house them this air is sucked
this is like this is like the only
secret quote unquote secret area that
I've I found previously that too much
devastated I'd the guy in the left is
like one of them he doesn't say anything
all he literally just goes he does go
that just he just says hello basically
yeah I was left kind of like what expect
are you okay oh now you're making like
this
it's death defying leaps me there we go
there we go so here let me see you seen
the post that blip down below kind of
teaches you stuff that you can just hang
on the corner if you run through it
which is exactly let's get in size as
well this is platform going it's to a
brothel I can't get to it so they will
do a couple more levels and I think then
you'll get like kind of just the game
I've died way less than I thought yes
I'm very pleased with myself squishy
it's calm yourself so I'm alright you're
not gonna get something I'm easy
no one's gonna squish today no I can't I
gotta go all the way around again it's
fine
hm I got a good got a hundred percent
the game Dave yeah I think this games
like 1199 on Steam 11 pounds 99 pence
constructs like $15 I was too busy think
talking about the price points and it's
PC only steam right at the moment yeah
but um I do believe it's gonna be coming
up Melanie is finished is just finished
a game you need to rest
so hey can we have a switch port I'm
sure Nikolas will be happy to do a
switch port of this ah no the team is
gonna go we'll go to arid flats number
10 and then we'll call it oh sorry
see all you could do until these lowers
just make a noise
yeah that's familiar
Oh Isis expect that launch
if you hold xeo higher ah and I highly
recommend this game right like I said
one people scratch that super me boys I
didn't know I had what's come up here
happens if I wait I feel like it's gonna
bring up like a deer spring chili or
something I can bounce on no never know
Oh screw you guys ah are you supposed to
get though then it might be something
like end up and unlike a level above it
or something and then oh and I drop down
yeah drop down oh that was our flats 10
all right we're gonna leave it there one
more one more one more
right what you want to do this one on
one more on this one on one more yes
this one looks like a pain in the butt
[Applause]
but I do this thank you all so much for
watching if you enjoyed the video hit
the like button make sure you subscribe
to GameSpot for more videos like this
like this one nice I gotta finish this
level though I gotta finish this level
in the meantime you can follow us on
twitter i'm at or h i'm at a regular
Dave please don't come on it's my bad
play-by-play we in this boys thank you
so much see you next time goodbye
bye
you